[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  just a little posturing  just see the contact on his walk yeah i  mean wasn't tobias going to walk over to  the bench  and a foul or a tactical is  issued as dybal and tucker get into it  now niang is there as well  [Applause]  and mb trying to  calm niang  i didn't see the initial  sort of confrontation there  but they were interchanging each other's  faces right after the whistle  we're gonna see it tucker set a screen  and then  went into the eyeball  shot in the back and then chicken winged  him  across the shoulder  and obviously  matisse devil took some some umbrage  with that  [Applause]  they're gonna take a look at  everything that transpired here  with tucker thiebel and niang  one thing doc rivers told us earlier in  the season he said  niang has some nasty in him said you  need that  what auerbach used to say you need some  guys with nasty niang willing to come  over there we know